What are your thoughts on taking a moxicillin after cavitation surgery, my pathology report came back off the charge and he said it was
most extensive or did he say most expensive or do you say extensive report he ever got back so you're talking about your pathology report for the
cavitation I hope. And so if they're doing the cavitation surgery, hopefully you're going to a biological dentist that's this is coming from
using the moxicillin is a preventative measure as they're going to they're cleaning things up, they're spewing out a lot of bacteria. That's the idea.
And if they're spewing a lot of bacteria, the chance of you getting a bacterial infection goes up.
And that's not on top of it. And even if you're getting a tooth extracted, many times you'll be given a prescription or a moxicillin because the chance of getting an infection because of the recent
extraction goes up. Is there anything wrong with taking a moxicillin for several days? Well, yes and no. So taking a moxicillin any antibiotic is going to, of course, throw off your gut microbiota. However, there's been research that says taking
and a probiotic with your antibiotic greatly reduces the negative effects and the microbiota.
Interested in this study, it didn't even make any difference what variety of probiotics the person took, which was very interesting, I thought, but just taking a probiotic reduced the
the damage of the microbiota. However, there's still going to be damage. And how do you get your microbiota back by eating a variety of different foods that are good, organic foods that don't have natural microbiota in them that you're recolonizing your cut.
So, um, you gotta weigh it out, you know, it's, I took some moxicillin, honestly, it was, I don't know, maybe a month ago, when I started getting
lime symptoms, really bad. I felt really ill and I thought this is exactly how my lime, I had lime three times. And I always caught it in the acute phase that I always took an antibiotic. Now, understand, I, this is the fourth time I've ever taken antibiotics in my life.
And I only took it for two days. So I, if it was a lime, I don't know, or sure positive. I didn't do a test because I think immediate lime tests are worthless because the time you get to test back, you could have moved into a chronic phase. So, um,
but I, it felt the exact same. I didn't notice a bullseye, but I, my lifestyle is what I'm not in the office doing things like this. I'm outside. We have a humongous garden.
We have 20 acres. I'm constantly working on the yard.
And, um, it's so constantly picking up ticks and stuff like that too. And then deer ticks, you just don't know. So it's, um,
uh, you know, there's pros and cons to it. I just do how sick I got with lime disease that it was worth taking two days of a mox sill and taking the probiotics and pumping it back up. I don't think there was, you know, a whole lot of ill effect on my gut, though. There are always this effect on your gut. So you got to weigh out the pros and cons of those things. So, um, I think it's something like that. It might be wise.
It's to take antibiotic for a short period of time.